bonjour georges kiejman au heat merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france votre réaction tout
d'abord à cette tribune des généraux qui
qui suscite beaucoup la polémique on a
entendu florence parly parler d'un
d'insurrection qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
bonjour donc effectivement j'ai moi-même
réagi et cette tribune en publié dans
marianne
hier moi j'étais personnellement et
choqué par la tournure de cette ces deux
tribunes non pas par certains constats
avec lesquels je suis en accord mais
avec la manière dont ça se termine cette
tribune qui est littéralement un appel à
l'insurrection et athis le feu de la
guerre civile
et c'est bien évidemment inacceptable
d'autant plus qu'on a eu immédiatement
la réaction enfin deux jours après de
madame marine le pen candidate à la
présidence de la france en dix ans qui a
été en accord on ne peut pas je crois
quand on est percé les politiques être
en accord avec des militaires qui je le
rappelle ne sont pas actives et qui
appelle à une forme de guerre civile et
justement puisqu'il ne sont pas
d'activer ce qu' ils sont dans la
liberté en tout cas de pouvoir exprimer
ce qu'il pense mais on est toujours en
liberté d'exprimer ce que l'on pense
alors il faut quand même noter que ce
sont des militaires à la retraite
quand on dit et gérald es ça veut dire
qu'ils font partie de la deuxième
section ce sont des militaires une
retraite pour la plupart d'entre eux ils
sont à la retraite depuis très très
longtemps donc il n'exprime pas
nécessairement la vie de l'institution
militaire faut que ce soit bien clair
mais néanmoins qu'il soit à la retraite
ou qu'ils ne soient même pas militaire
appelée une manière ou d'une autre à la
guerre civile et un problème dans une
démocratie parce que pour vous il
appelle à la guerre civile on va
regarder cet extrait justement qui a
suscité justement là
la polémique et la colère des membres du
gouvernement regardé par contre si rien
n'est entrepris le laxisme continuera à
se répandre inexorablement dans la
société provoquant au final une
explosion et l'intervention de nos
camarades d'actifs dans une mission
périlleuse de protection de nos valeurs
civilisationnelles et de sauvegarde de
nos compatriotes sur le territoire
national donc pour vous savez ce que
c'est cette phrase qui pose problème on
peut l'interpréter un peu différemment
un appel à l'insurrection ou pas
d'ailleurs
oui c'est évident à voir cette phrase
qui pose problème mais pour le moins on
pourrait dire que pour le moins elle est
mal tourner car justement elle peut
prêter à interprétation et certains le
font comme étant un appel à la guerre
civile car il est quand même parler de
valeurs civilisationnelles et non pas de
défense de la république ou de
l'intégrité du territoire ou de
principes républicains
quelque chose dans l'armée n'est pas
censé s'occuper
et puis encore une fois on peut être
d'accord avec les généraux sur sur
certains des problèmes qu'il se lève il
ne soulève pas tous les problèmes la
société mézin soulève un particulier qui
est le séparatisme les certains
quartiers perdus de la république et la
nécessité de reprendre le contrôle
bien évidemment mais est ce que vous
imaginez
ou est ce que ceux qui défendent cette
cet appel s'imagine ce que veut dire
prendre le contrôle
militairement dans les quartiers perdus
de la république et vous ne reprend on
se retrouverait immédiatement puisque
les militaires ne sont pas entraînés
bien évidemment au maintien de l'ordre
mais ils sont en train de la faire la
guerre on se retrouvait dans une
situation à la sarajevo aulas falloudja
avec énormément de victimes et que
chaque d'autres du côté des militaires
et de la population et une situation
politique gravement dégradées alors que
les problèmes qu'elles soulèvent peuvent
être réglés par la volonté politique
certes que lapin le gouvernement mais
nous avons suffisamment de policiers de
gendarmes de loi déjà pour agir si on
veut réellement agir contre les
séparatistes en france certains élus en
seine-saint-denis notamment disent qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment de policiers et
on a vu
samia ghali notamment à marseille
demandé à l'intervention de l'armée dans
certains quartiers ça pourrait être une
prérogative ou pas selon vous alors
samia ghali a fait cette demande depuis
longtemps
madame ségolène royal également manuel
valls donc ce ne sont pas que des gens
de droite qui font ce genre de demande
mais ce sont des demandes insensé encore
une fois quand l'on fait cela c'est que
on a perdu tout pied et toute réalité
avec ce que cela veut dire une
intervention militaire à l'intérieur de
notre pays à chaque fois ça a mal tourné
le 19e siècle en est émaillé ce sont les
révoltes de 1830 1148 de la commune de
paris s'est plus récemment après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
le milieu intérieur jules moch qui a
fait intervenir l'armée contre les
grévistes et toujours des morts c'est
toujours a ajouté du sang à la misère et
ça ne règle en rien les problèmes car
les problèmes à régler sont politiques
donc je ne je ne comprends pas comment
ces politiques là envisage de régler
quoi que ce soit en envoyant des
militaires qui ne sont pas entraînés au
maintien de l'ordre et qui n'ont pas
l'armement pour on va parler d'oeil si
je peux me permettre
tu peux paraître on a vu déjà la cli
gilet jaune ce que signifie une
répression d'un mouvement populaire
comme les gilet jaune par des policiers
n'entraîner car la plus grande partie
des centaines de blessés graves
qu'ont subis les gilets jaunes l'ont été
par des forces qui ne sont ni les crs
les gendarmes mobiles qui eux sans
entraîner entraîné au maintien de
l'ordre
ils l'ont été par des policiers actia de
nous des armes
et encore ce ne sont pas des armes de
guerre mais qui se sont retrouvés à les
utiliser à mal les utiliser on en a vu
les conséquences
et vous parlez aussi dans votre tribune
de l'utilisation de la force armée pour
l'opération sentinelles
est ce que justement c'est le rôle de
l'armée d'assurer ses missions de
de sécurité en tout cas de lutte
antiterroriste l'armée peut combattre le
terrorisme le fait le fait par exemple
où continuent à le faire ou au sahel
mais sur le territoire national cette
opération mixant de sentinelle ne sert à
rien il y a un rapport parlementaire qui
a été rédigé déjà à l'époque du
président françois hollande montrant que
ça n'a quasiment tout ça n'a aucune
incidence sur le terrorisme par contre
cela fatigue
nos armées qui sont déjà sur utiliser et
qui sont obligés de rajouter après des
opérations extérieures des périodes sur
le terrain et cela les expose comme on
l'a vu à les attaques de terroristes
amateurs qui se sont eux qui s'en sont
pris à certains de nos militaires dont
comment cette opération sentinel contre
le terrorisme ne sert à rien est ce que
vous comprenez néanmoins au delà de
l'interprétation d'une insurrection pas
le coup de gueule de cette tribune de
ces militaires mais encore une fois je
sais ce que j'ai écrit dans ma tribune
et je vous le dis je comprend une partie
de leurs de leurs remarques d'autres le
font ce ne sont pas les premiers se
faire bref sur ce que l'on appelle les
quartiers perdus delà de la république
mais leur interprétation est quand même
très largement biaisée et il faut
rappeler que tant monsieur fabre
bernadac général fabre bernadac que bien
d'autres des généraux signataires sont
soit membre soit ont été membres soit
très proche de rassemblement national
pour le moins c'est biaisé monsieur
fabre bernadac s'occuper de la sécurité
et du service de monsieur jean-marie le
pen
après certains sont défendant et parle
de récupération politique
certains s'en défend mais leur l'un de
leurs premiers signataires
peut-être devrait-il de reprocher à
certains de leurs signataires dont
monsieur fabre bernadac met en tout cas
c'est une manière biaisée et
inconséquente 2
tenter de régler un problème réel dans
notre société mais au public
est ce qu'ils veulent réellement régler
un problème est ce que ce n'est pas
plutôt un appel aux gouvernements à agir
et en cela ont-ils raison mais bien
évidemment qu'ils ont raison de demander
au gouvernement d'agir mais il y a comme
une menace encore une fois à la fin de
cet appel puisque si le gouvernement
n'agissait pas élise il faudrait que
l'armée intervienne
on va demander du plan antiterroriste
qui est présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres justement dans ce climat de
ressenti en tout cas d'insécurité en
france après ce qui s'est passé est
évidemment contre la policière qui a été
tué dans son commissariat par un
terroriste que pensez vous de ce texte
dont dont un des articles justement
renforce les prérogatives du service de
renseignements pour pouvoir tracer les
historiques des pages internet des
terroristes potentiels en tout cas de
tout à chacun
écoutez notre pays se caractérise par
une faiblesse de son personnel politique
qui dès qu'il y à un dès qu'il ya un
attentat dans notre pays légifère et
propose une nouvelle loi
donc on a régulièrement des lois qui
sont qui sont proposés après des actes
terroristes
je vois que c'est inutile nous avons
déjà un dispositif légal
parfaitement adapté à la lutte
antiterroriste et il faudrait surtout
l'appliquer et donc ce volet
supplémentaire qui doit être ajoutée
c'est-à-dire remonter les files les
historiques des collections des
terroristes est quelque chose qui va
s'ajouter aux lois liberticides qui vont
s'appliquer à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
alors que nous avons déjà les moyens et
il faut saluer nos forces de
renseignement et aux forces
antiterroristes qui chaque mois
arrête avant qu'ils ne soient commis des
terroristes qui vous souhaiteraient
commettre des actes terroristes
maintenant il est tout un volet anti
terroriste qui n'est pas mis en oeuvre
il faut systématiquement le rappeler et
ce gouvernement ne le
bah c'est s'attaquer à ceux qui
financent les
les mosquées les plus les plus
dangereuses à ceux qui financent les
associations qui véhiculent l'idéologie
salafiste et frériste et ce gouvernement
ne les fait pas car cela demanderait est
bien de faire un peu plus pression sur
certains pays comme l'arabie saoudite et
le qatar
on va écouter justement là est la raison
pour laquelle ce plan est présenté
aujourd'hui c'est une source interne à
l'exécutif qui le dit regardez l'idée
est de montrer qu'on est mobilisé au
plus haut niveau sur le terrorisme de
répondre aussi aux attaques sur la
faiblesse de notre politique
antiterroriste ou migratoire est ce que
finalement la cette présentation du
texte qui reprend finalement des
anciennes lois c'est un moyen d'occuper
le terrain pour faire taire les
critiques sur le manque de réaction
justement sur ces questions sécuritaires
oui sûrement c'est une manière de de
montrer que l'on fait quelque chose ce
gouvernement s'illustre sur de nombreux
sujets par une suractivité en
communication dès qu'il ya un problème
mais agit fort peu en profondeur et
c'est malheureux il faut néanmoins
saluer une chose c'est le renforcement
du financement du renseignement u10
humain qui est mais d'abord ce qui n'est
pas assez financer
nous manquons de personnel apte à faire
du renseignement humain c'est-à-dire
infiltré les réseaux terroristes et il
est la pratique le montre très
clairement c'est la manière la plus
efficace de lutter contre les groupes
terroristes et non pas l'application de
la méthode dite venant des états unis
qui consiste à avoir un sorte de 1984 de
big brother de contrôle permanent de
toutes les têtes de tous les échanges
car cela a créé une masse de données
colossal qui est même demande à être
traités or cette manière de faire permet
de remonter un peu les filières une fois
qu'un acte terroriste et cauet commis
mais très peu d'agir en amont et
d'éviter un acte terroriste on va parler
un petit peu de la crise sanitaire pour
terminer cet entretien georges kiejman
au beach
la situation sanitaire n'est pas
brillante néanmoins le chef de l'état
envisage de desserrer les restrictions
sanitaires d'ici à la mi-mai est allé
jusqu'à juillet on va écouter ce
qu'avait dit jean castex sur les fameux
variant qui inquiète les scientifiques
olivier ferrand a dit le contraire
quelques jours plus tard regarder je
constate seulement tenir cette ligne que
les variants notamment brésiliens sud
africain non seulement sont très peu
nombreux ce décor nationale mais en même
temps comme ces dernières semaines et
graisser il est impératif de tenir cette
ligne
grosse semaine une augmentation de la
proportion du variante sud africains
notamment au petit couronne parisien qui
représentait 6% des diagnostics et qui
en représentent désormais 10 %
voilà on sait pas trop à quoi s'en tenir
d'un côté ça baisse de l'autre côté ça
monte
que pensez vous de cette communication
moi je crois que sur la communication du
gouvernement sur la crise de la commune
tout a été dit que ce soit sur les
masques et respirateurs l'oxygène est
maintenant plus les vaccins maintenait
les variantes du gouvernement a dit tout
et son contraire a parfois menti à la
population
moi je vous rappellerai ce qui s'est
passé avec le variant à britanniques
vers le mois de novembre début décembre
ce gouvernement disait qu'il n'y a pas
de problème il ya à peine 5 % de
variants britannique en france tout est
100 contre tous tout est sous contrôle
et on voit bien où on en est c'est à
dire avec un variant britannique
maintenant qu'est devenue majoritaire
massif qui fait d'énormes dégâts dans la
population
il n'y a pas de raison vu que ce
gouvernement a été incapable de fermer
les frontières et de fermiers
intelligemment les frontières toujours
aujourd'hui que ces variants ne se
propage pas surtout s'ils sont plus
virulents il se propageront de toute
façon nous sommes aujourd'hui alors
qu'on parle pour des raisons
politiciennes
relatives à l'élection régionale de
déconfinement partiel pour la mi-mai
alors que on a trente mille cas
enregistrés tous les jours c'est à dire
un très très très fort très très fort
taux de circulation du vaccin
on est dans une situation où il est bien
évidemment ça va continuer à exploser
parce que ce gouvernement ne fait pas la
seule chose qui est efficace et que nous
montre des gouvernements comme le
gouvernement de corée où ce qui se passe
à taiwan c'est de tester et massivement
et de maître par de versoix de de
confiner les gens contaminés de manière
obligatoire pendant deux semaines afin
d'éviter de tout fermer et de détruire à
notre économie ce qui est
malheureusement le cas voilà mais je ne
suis pas étonné que vers ans et mathieu
castex ne soit pas d'accord elles ne
disent pas la même chose
c'est le cas depuis plus d'un an merci
beaucoup georges qu'ils mènent vite je
rappelle qu'à des tests massif néanmoins
mais qu'il n'y a pas forcément contraint
de confinement derrière merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'avoir répondu ce matin en
direct à nos questions sur rtl france